on a la chance d'avoir avec mu corée qui
dernièrement bleus
ok
et
[Musique]
les eaux
dépêche-toi les eaux on va être en
retard dépêche toi aller au web je
supporte pas le seul où il faut tout
vous dire on est encore et on est à
séoul
on est parti sur salon pour voir des
start-up coréenne plutôt cool je vous en
parle dans quelques jours et aujourd'hui
je vous parle de cette montre celle là
la fossiles ku qui est bien mais toute
chose il faut qu'on réussisse à à bouger
parce qu'on a rendez vous pour aller
voir ou des stats de cosmétiques bizarre
d'ailleurs soitec coréenne il ya des
problèmes parce qu'on est important avec
3h28 l'étroit dans cette chute en france
il est 10h30 si on arrive et pas mal
d'années tu es aujourd'hui il fait
presque bleu à paris d'abord eu un petit
peu le le brouillard pollution et là le
ciel bleu donc on est pas mal alors à
rio
[Musique]
sans manger il fait une chaleur
impossible on va se parler de cette
monde dans quelques instants le temps de
m'asseoir aussi une petite balade on va
sur un petit con pu se rencontrer des
étudiants apparaître cosmétiques de
plein de trucs intéressants d'innovation
dont on voit la photo cool il fait une
chaleur c'est étouffant ici en corée
mais c'est vachement sympa c'est très
agaçant les très nombreux comme gamecom
comme les alors on a une bonne petite
équipe on est plutôt pas mal mais nous
sommes expliqués
ça y est c'est monsieur gros
[Rires]
[Musique]
valeo
on est pas mal donc on est dans un lieu
où on parle de cosmétiques de
technologie qos critiquer complique les
opérations truc à l'innovation pour la
cosmétique
on a la chance d'avoir avec moïse koré
qui est derrière mon bleu hier à ok
et on rigole comme quoi se mêlent dans
my name is hier j'ai donné qu'aucun
hockey nice to meet you you continue ou
youtube il ya ya ya
pochon 5e et rexona merci du make-up au
pouvoir se faire beau on va s'enlever
les rides tu en penses quoi je pense que
ça marche regarde oui c'est ça c'est ça
je vous dis pas mon âge à 65 ans à
sochaux mais ça ne revienne mais qu'à
bientôt 66
bravo bon de retour à l'hôtel justement
je voulais vous parler de cette non
c'est la faux cils ku l'année dernière
smartwatch de fossiles je sais pas si
vous connaissez de lait petit monte là
il ya différentes tailles
vous l'avez soit en 41 soit 43 mm plutôt
sommes plutôt fan moi j'aime bien je
laime bien pour plusieurs raisons la
toute première c'est qu'elle est
vachement discrète elle est vachement
légère ça c'est assez appréciable alors
sauf si on veut effectivement il montre
un peu plus grosses comme cette bo avait
je vous ai présenté l'autre jour ou
alors comme la samsung la galaxy ovation
peu plus imposante assez masculine cela
je trouve au contraire justement assez
discrète pas mal elle est vachement bien
vous avez un bracelet en silicone qui
dans l'absolu et bien est ce que j'aime
bien que ce bras sans silicone ce qui
s'attache une façon un petit peu
standard c'est à dire que vous allez
attaché pour faire face à une autre un
peu classique donc du coup vous n'allez
pas vous arracher les poils
ce que je reproche souvent tout cas là
la watch d'apple c'est vraiment le fait
que si vous prenez de la cedh origine eh
bien vous fait bobo
si vous avez plein de poils comme moi ça
fait mal maintenant ce qui est
intéressant c'est que vous avez un écran
oled qui est plutôt de bonne qualité qui
est assez lumineux de 1,2 pouce et elle
est fluide justement parce que derrière
vous avez le snapdragon ou air 3100 qui
est pas mal qui est pas mal qui
fonctionne bien c'est pas la montre la
plus rapide je trouve que les mondes de
samsung avec un procès xylose va un peu
plus vite ou alors carrément celle
d'apple vont plus vite
néanmoins je trouve le rendu comme est
assez fluide à sékaly ça dépend bien
évidemment après des usages que vous
allez en avoir mais pour tout ce qui est
un petit peu standard cette somme des
sages notification pouvoir naviguer si
vous la charge et pas trop en mémoire ça
va vous pouvez franchement faire et elle
est vachement cali là-dessus ouvert
plein de choses avec le grand classique
c'est le
vidéo rythme cardiaque bon ça ça marche
bien ça va checkez votre rythme
cardiaque régulièrement dans la mesure
où vous faites du sport c'est bien si
vous faites pas de sport pouvait
surveiller la tachycardie
ça peut être bien aussi pour le côté un
peu glissante et sa marotte derrière
mais c'est vrai tu peux le 100 m tyson
mais s'il maladies importantes et à des
problèmes cardiaques talenteux
surveiller le mieux c'est quand même ça
donc mettre un bracelet un brassard ou
pointe attention encore une fois tu te
plantes ou bien on te voit pas alors
bien évidemment il ya du gps au cas où
vous perdez ça peut être plutôt bien
vous pouvez payer grâce au nfc avec les
google paye que je vous en parlais vous
avez were os de google qui est plutôt
cool donc vous pouvez effectivement payé
vous presser dans les transports en
commun bip un coup de monde ça marche
assez cool c'est bien évidemment une
montre qui est étanche jusqu'à 50 mètres
alors n'at il pas faire de la plongée
avec mais par contre dans l'idée vous
faites du sport vous transpirez où vous
prenez un peu d'eau vous allez faire la
natation avec voudra absolument aucun
problème donc ça c'est cool
vous pouvez soit même de la musique
directement intérieur et sinon si elle
est connecté en bluetooth avec votre
smartphone vous voyez les morceaux qui
cette fiche pouvez naviguer directement
depuis votre montre et changer la
musique sur votre smartphone donc ça
c'est cool et vous pouvez mettre de la
musique intérieure parce que vous avez 4
gigaoctets de stockage pour mettre de la
musique tout ce que vous voulez ce qui
vous fait plaisir mais des applications
non ça c'est aussi plutôt bien
bien évidemment je parle du bracelet en
silicone comme ça mais vous pouvez le
changer
là vous venez le d'éclipsé vous le
changez vous mettez ce que vous voulez
c'est plutôt bien aussi assez sympa
parce qu'on n'aime pas forcément ce
petit côté noir sont qu'un petit peu
plus décoratif
on peut le faire et bien évidemment pas
qu'il coup là tu sais que vous avez le
playsport avec toutes les applications
du clae store à venir télécharger à
venir installer là dessus alors il ya
vachement de choses pouvaient installer
des jeux pleins d'applications cool moi
j'ai notamment spotify a pour écouter de
la musique ça c'est vachement bien là
vous avez accès à toutes vos applis pour
la navigation est assez simple ouvrier
l'écran est bien très réactif vous avez
spotify votre google agenda le plat
histoire dans lequel et pouvoir tout
retrouver toutes les applis que vous
pouvez retrouver ici les applications
qui sont recommandées pour moi forgan a
pas mal alors ils m'ont recommandé
exercice de sept minutes
tu crois qu'ils ont compris que vous
avez pas mal d'appli pour le truc est
assez cool votre alarme bowling ça c'est
brink's à ma liste de courses assez bien
je l'utilisais j'aime bien pour aller
faire les courses comme ça surtout dans
maman pas forcément sur le smartphone
les contacts toutes les petites
catégories de sports de la montre
l'appli fosty enfin voilà il ya pas mal
de petites choses
c'est facile pour naviguer quand vous
êtes sur votre écran là haut up vous
allez à droite vous allez pouvoir
modifier les quarts
l'autre côté vous avez retrouvé votre
google assistant ça c'est plutôt bien
sur le banc toutes vos petites
notification et sur le haut vous arrivez
dans les paramètres de la montre voulait
s'appuyer ou modifier le cadran vous
avez le choix entre quelques cadres en
est si vous souhaitez pour venir en
télécharger après sur le net voilà moi
cela il va bien j'aimais plus ici j'ai
mon exercice
après à vous de voir en fonction de vos
besoins des applications santé que vous
utilisez des applications de sport que
vous utilisez elle tourne bien
évidemment sur ios et sur android vous
avez du bluetooth 4.2 vous avez du wifi
également c'est une honte que moi je
trouve plutôt bien en usage ce que
j'apprécie par dessus tout je dirais ça
côté un petit peu discrets alors ça
dépend vous ce que j'aime bien moi c'est
pour changer de montre régulièrement
celle là je laime bien fonction de
certaines occasions et à côté un peu
discret et surtout ce que ce que j'aime
par rapport à certaines que j'ai pu
utiliser ces webos que je trouve assez
intéressant notamment pour le ppt les
stores ça c'est un truc que j'aime bien
pour le côté un petit peu tracking de
l'activité physique alors je suis par un
grand sportif
donc je vais pas l'utiliser pour les
faire du vélo parce que je ne fais pas
de vélo je n'ai pas utilisé pour les
faire l'a constaté parce que je ne fais
pas de course à pied et encore moins de
natation je devrais je vais m'y mettre
donc je leur ai donc c'est cool mais si
je vous êtes sportives ou sportives
vous pouvez l'utiliser pour ça c'est
vachement intéressant mais le truc que
je reprocherais un peu cette montre mais
pas les cinq à sept manches tout
reproche aussi à beaucoup de monde c'est
l'autonomie qui est beaucoup trop petite
vous la gardez un jour et demi pas de
jour un jour et demi ce qui fait que si
vous ne pensez pas la recharger tous les
soirs et bien le lendemain milieu de
journée et votre note vous pouvez plus
utiliser
alors rassurez vous il ya quand même un
mode qui permet d'utiliser à minima vous
allez avoir un écran qui va afficher
l'heure c'est bien donc elle remplira
son rôle de montres mais plus tous deux
mondes connectés
ça c'est voilà un peu le truc un peu en
dessous mais une fois de plus c'est pas
propre à cette montre c'est un peu là la
maladie entre guillemets des mondes
connectés
la batterie est pas génial l'autonomie
est pas folle néanmoins pour les
services rendus c'est bien mais par
contre vous vraiment penser à la
recharger tous les soirs après à côté de
ça la recharge est assez rapide en une
heure vous l'avez rechargée à 80 85 %
vous laisser un peu plus d'une heure
vous êtes à 100% donc c'est vrai que ça
pas vous prendre trop de temps vous
n'êtes pas besoin de la laisser pendant
des heures et des heures et des heures
pour quelles charges si par exemple vous
l'utiliser un jour et demi quand le
milieu de la journée vous voulez que
vous allez bloqué alors que vous voulez
anticipe un petit peu leur charge
si vous êtes au bureau au toit que vous
avez une prise pas loin vous prenez vous
chargez ça navigue donc ça c'est plutôt
cool donc dans l'absolu expérience
plutôt positive
sur sa bien par là toi ça va vous allez
bien bon c'est un peu de travail je vais
mettre de travers
expérience plutôt positif dans cette non
déjà trouve bien je trouve intéressante
je suis assez satisfait c'est une honte
que je continuerai à utiliser son
problème parce que j'aime bien ce petit
format
après à vous de me dire ce que vous en
pensez comment vous la trouvez est ce
que justement vous avez ce petit format
le fait que ce soit une honte qu'il soit
pas trop grosse est ce que c'est un truc
qui peut vous plaire espèrent au
contraire vous et à moi je voudrais un
truc un peu plus gros peut-être masculin
dans les clichés dans les stéréotypes
reconnaissent l'utilisent dans les
usages démontrer ce que voudrait quelque
chose avec un plus grand écran à côté de
ça vous avez deux petits boutons qui
sont personnalisables vous pouvez les
mettre vraiment comme vous voulez pour
faire ce que vous ayez donc ça c'est
cool également et la navigation en elle
même est assez intuitive
le prix c'est 245 euros si vous
intéresse je vous ai mis un lien en bas
dans la description pour veiller à vous
de me dire ce que vous en pensez comment
vous la trouvez alors ya pléthore de
mondes connectés mais il faut s'il est
connu pour sa qualité au niveau des
montres c'est la première fois que je
teste une monde connecté fossiles j'en
avais déjà vu l'année dernière quand
j'étais parti à l'ifa à berlin
j'aimais pas eu l'occasion pour vous en
parler en vidéo c'est aujourd'hui chose
faite donc ça c'est cool a vous de me
dire comment vous la trouvez celle-là en
elle-même et par rapport à la
concurrence par rapport à ce qui est sur
le marché et peut-être par rapport à la
menthe que vous vous avez vous marquez
tout ça mais quant à moi je vais bientôt
rentrer retour demain en france onze
heures d'avion jusqu'à paris c'est long
mais c'est pas grave si sur lesquels
plutôt pas mal en corée à l'autre bout
du monde
on est heureux et dites nous en
commentaire vous avez bien qu'il ya des
gens non en fond qu'il faut tu as du mal
à parler après wayne hall a refait solo
et dites nous si vous aime bien en
commentaire s'il ya des gens qui aiment
et dites-moi aux commentaires j'aimerais
bien qu'ils aient des gens en font
qu'ils font bordel ah ouais je veux dire
des perturbateurs ouais c'est ça
exactement
ouais c'est ça mais je pense qu'on aime
bien la perturbation du plaisir raid
retourne faire des photos allez voilà
salut bisous à plus tard